Good morning, John, I'm going to Comic-Con,
but we need to talk
and maybe we should've been talking about this
for a while, and I know it's not super fun
but the internet has become like
a less...a less kind place.
It's unpleasant to admit, as
a person who really loves the internet,
but it would appear that we've entered
into a bit of an age of outrage.
This is not a problem with humans,
or with the internet;
it's a problem of humans mixed with the internet.
I think that we'd all kind of like to talk
as much as we're listened to.
Which works if it's a two person conversation,
like, one person talks, the other person talks
50/50 split is a pretty good thing.
And I think we've all felt this with like a six or eight person conversation,
that it can get a little frustrating
when you can't get a word in edgewise
cause you're just not the loudest or
the most eloquent person in the room.
In a billion-person conversation
(and yeah, I'm in San Diego now
'cause I had to get on my plane)
it's more like just a deafening roar
accompanied by feelings of powerlessness.
I think we are in the first age of the
social internet and the job of that age
is to suck us in and capture our eyeballs
and keep them as close to those revenue-generating advertisements as possible.
Research has shown that even over cute things or inspirational things or amazing things,
angering things, things that outrage us; that's what
our brains, on average, are most prone to sharing.
The problem is, whether it makes us angry
definitely matters to whether we share it;
whether it's true or not, whether it's productive or not...not really a factor.
Maybe we need to enter a new stage of the social internet:
One where we choose and we create places on the internet that aren't just addictive or distracting
but instead bring personal and societal satisfaction.
Throughout our lives we know this:
we have to work to keep ourselves healthy
and to keep our relationships healthy
and to keep our communities healthy
and the internet is a huge part of our communities now.
And a lot of it is unhealthy.
These things don't take care of themselves,
and we had this idea early on that they would,
but the land in my city is not responsible for the wellbeing of the community that exists on top of it.
Keeping that community healthy is the job of the government and the citizens,
and so keeping internet communities healthy is the job of the leaders of those communities,
whether they're the owners or the people
working for those communities,
or the leaders in those communities,
and also the citizens of those communities.
Without conscious leadership, these communities
decay, and they destroy themselves,
and they leach out into the real world where they harm actual individuals humans and our culture.
I've linked to a couple of videos in the description that helped me think about this stuff well
if you wanna watch some other perspectives on it.
I've been so inspired by seeing the positive effects of the "plussing" that we've been doing.
For me the best comments are content themselves;
they add instead of just react.
So I've been loving it but there are some people
who have pointed out problems with plussing,
particularly that it makes discussion
more difficult when it's in a sea of pluses.
For those people, a nerdfighter named Melvin
created a Chrome extension that will
remove the "+" comments from YouTube
comments. So that's...thank you Melvin!
I've always been proud of this community
and I have always known that it's
composed almost entirely of kind, thoughtful people.
I know that because of the comment section, I know that because I've met so many of you in the real world.
I know it because at Vidcon this year
we had volunteers going around
and giving these wristbands to anyone who would
donate to help the families and the victims of the Pulse nightclub shooting.
And then Vidcon and Universal Talent Agency and YouTube all matched those donations
until we raised almost $40,000.
And we actually have some left over,
so if you want to continue supporting that effort
you can go to dftba.com, where they're for sale for $5.
But in the end, in a world of infinite content,
when "shareability" is king,
sometimes kindness and empathy
don't play particularly well,
and so we start to forget they exist.
But I do think that we're gonna start heading into
a new age of the social internet
And it's not gonna happen immediately or anything,
where platforms and the users of those platforms
work together to actually promote good community,
and kindness, and empathy,
and that's certainly happening
in certain corners of the internet,
and I'm very proud that it's happening right here.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.